i've talked a lot about the importance
of hemoglobin in our red blood cell so i
thought i would dedicate an entire video
to hemoglobin one because it's important
but also it explains a lot about how
the hemoglobin or the red blood cells
depending on what level you want to
operate no and you know i have to use no
end quotes these aren't sentient beings
but how do they know when to pick up the
oxygen and when to drop off the oxygen
so this right here this is actually a
picture of a hemoglobin of a hemoglobin
protein right there this is hemoglobin
hemoglobin it's made up of four amino
acid chains that's one of them the and
those are the other two we're not going
to go into the detail of that but these
look like little curly ribbons if you
imagine them they're a bunch of
molecules and amino acids and then
they're curled around like that so this
on some level describes its shape and
then in each of those
groups or in each of those chains you
have a heme group
you have a heme group here in green
heme group that's where you get the heme
and hemoglobin from you have four heme
groups and the globins are essentially
describing the rest of it the protein
structures the four peptide chains now
this heme group this is pretty
interesting
it actually is a porphyrin
structure and if you watch the video on
chlorophyll you'd remember a porphyrin
structure but at the very center of it
in chlorophyll we had a magnesium ion
but at the very center of hemoglobin we
have an iron
we have an iron ion
iron ion and this is where the oxygen
binds so on this hemoglobin you have
four major binding sites for oxygen you
have right there
maybe right there a little bit behind
right there
and right there now why is hemoglobin
well you know oxygen will bind very well
here
but
hemoglobin has several properties that
one make it really good at binding
oxygen and then also really good at
dumping oxygen when it needs to dump
oxygen
so in it it exhibits something called
cooperative binding cooperative
cooperative binding and this is just the
principle that once it binds to one
oxygen molecule so let's say one oxygen
molecule binds right there it is it
changes the shape in such a way that the
other sites are more likely to bind
oxygen
so this makes it you know one binding
one binding
makes the other bindings more likely
makes
other
bindings
more
likely now you say okay that's fine that
makes it a very good oxygen acceptor
when it's uh traveling through the the
capillary the pulmonary capillaries and
oxygen is diffusing from the alveoli
that makes it really good at picking up
the oxygen but how does it know when to
dump the oxygen this is an interesting
question when
to dump oxygen it doesn't have eyes or
some type of gps system that says oh you
know what
this guy is running right now and so
he's generating a lot of carbon dioxide
right now in these capillaries and he
needs a lot of oxygen in these
capillaries surrounding his quadriceps i
need to deliver oxygen it doesn't know
it's in the quadriceps how does how does
the hemoglobin know to let go of the
oxygen there
and that's a byproduct of what we call
allosteric inhibition which is a very
fancy word but the concept's actually
pretty straightforward allosteric
inhibition
and when you talk about allosteric
anything
it's often used in the context of
enzymes you're talking about the idea
that things bind to other parts allo
means other so you're binding to other
parts of the protein or the enzyme and
what enzymes are just proteins and it
affects the ability of the protein or
the enzyme to do what it normally does
so hemoglobin is allosterically
inhibited by carbon dioxide
by carbon dioxide and by protein by
protons so carbon dioxide can bond to
other parts of the hemoglobin i don't
know the exact spots and so can protons
so remember acidity just means a high
concentration of protons so if you're an
acidic environment protons can bond
maybe i'll do the protons in this pink
color protons
which are just hydrogen without
electrons right
protons can bond to certain parts of our
protein and it makes it harder for them
to hold on to the oxygen so when you
when you're in the presence of a lot of
carbon dioxide or an acidic environment
this thing is going to let go of its
oxygen and it just happens to be that
that's a really good time to let go of
your oxygen let's go back to this guy
running he's running
there's a lot of activity in these cells
right here in his quadriceps
they're releasing a lot of carbon
dioxide into into the capillaries into
well at that point they're turning
they're going from arteries into veins
and they need a lot of oxygen which is a
great time for the hemoglobin to dump
their oxygen so it's really good
that hemoglobin is allosterically
inhibited by carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide
joins on certain parts of it it starts
letting go of his oxygen that's exactly
where in the body the oxygen is needed
now you're saying wait what about this
acidic environment how does this come
into play well it turns out that most of
the carbon dioxide is actually
disassociated it actually disassociates
it does go into the plasma but it
actually gets turned into carbonic acid
so i'll just write a little
formula right here so if you have a
little bit of if you have some co2 and
you mix it
with the water i mean most of our blood
the plasma it's water so you take some
carbon dioxide you mix it with water and
you have it in the presence of a of an
enzyme and this enzyme exists in red
blood cells it's called carbonic
anhydrase
carbonic
anhydrase
a reaction will occur that'll that'll
essentially you'll end up with carbonic
acid you'll end up with we have h2
c o three and it's all balanced we have
three oxygens two hydrogens one carbon
and this it's called carbonic acid
because it gives away hydrogen protons
very easily acids disassociate into
their uh conjugate base and their in
there and hydrogen protons very easily
so carbonic acid
carbonic acid
disassociates very easily it's an it's
an acid although right in some type of
an equilibrium right there if any of
this notation really confuses you if you
want more detail on it watch some of the
the chemistry videos on acid
dissociation and equilibrium reactions
and all of that but it's essentially can
give away one of these hydrogens so
you're left with but just the proton and
it keeps the electron of that hydrogen
so you're left with a hydrogen proton
plus well you gave away one of the
hydrogens you just have one hydrogen
this is actually
by a bicarbonate ion so
this is bicarbonate right there but it
only gave away the proton kept the
electron so you have a minus sign so
it's the the all of the charge adds up
to neutral and that's neutral over there
so if i'm in my if i'm in a capillary of
the leg let me see if i can draw this
so let's say i'm in the capillary of my
leg
let me do a neutral color
so this is a capillary of my leg i've
zoomed in just one part of the capillary
you know it's always branching off and
over here i have a bunch of you know
muscle cells
right here that are generating a lot of
carbon dioxide
they're generating a lot of carbon
dioxide and they need oxygen well what's
going to happen
well i have my red blood cells flowing
along it's actually interesting red
blood cells that the capital are 25
percent their diameter is 25 percent
larger than the smallest capillaries so
essentially they get squeezed as they go
through the small capillaries which a
lot of people believe helps them release
their contents so releases maybe some of
the oxygen that they have in them so you
have a red blood cell that's coming in
here it's being squeezed through
this capillary right here
it has a bunch of hemoglobin and when i
say a bunch you might as well know right
now each red blood cell has 270 million
hemoglobin proteins 270 million and if
you total up the hemoglobin in the
entire body it's huge because we have
let me write this number down this is we
have 20 to 30
trillion
red blood cells
we have 20 to 30 trillion red blood
cells and each of those 20 to 30
trillion red blood cells have 270
million hemoglobin
hemoglobin
proteins in them so we have a lot of
hemoglobin so anyway that was a little
bit of a so actually red blood cells
make up roughly 25 percent of all of the
cells in our body we have about 100
trillion or a little bit more give or
take i've never sat down and counted
them but anyway we have a bunch we have
270 million hemoglobin particles or
proteins in each red blood cell explains
why the red blood cells had to shed
their nucleuses to make space for all of
those hemoglobins they're carrying
oxygen
so right here
so right here we're dealing with this is
an artery
right it's coming from the heart the red
blood cell is going in that direction
and then it's going to shed its oxygen
and then it's going to become a vein now
what's going to happen is
what's going to happen is you have this
carbon dioxide you have a high
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
muscle cell and eventually by just by a
diffusion gradient ends up let me
let me do that same color
ends up in the blood plasma
ends up in the blood plasma just like
that and some of it can make its way
across the membrane into the actual into
the actual red blood cell in the red
blood cell you have this carbonic
anhydrase which makes the carbon dioxide
disassociate into or essentially become
carbonic acid which then can release
protons so let me do the protons out
here
well those protons we just learned can
allosterically inhibit the uptake of
oxygen by hemoglobin so those protons
start bonding to different parts and
even the carbon dioxide that hasn't been
reacted with that can also
allosterically inhibit the hemoglobin so
it also bonds to other parts and that
changes the shape of the hemoglobin
protein just enough that it can't hold
on to its oxygens that well it starts
letting go and just as we said we had
cooperative binding the more oxygens you
have on the the better it is at
accepting more the opposite happens when
you start letting go of oxygen it
becomes harder to retain the other ones
so then all of the oxygens let go so
this is at least in my mind it's a
brilliant brilliant mechanism because
the oxygen gets let go just where it
needs to let go it doesn't it doesn't
just say oh i'm in i've i've now i'm now
uh i've left an artery and i'm now in a
vein you know maybe i've gone through
some capillaries right here and i'm
going to go back to a vein let me
release my oxygen because then it would
just release the oxygen willingly
throughout the body this system by being
allosterically inhibited by carbon
dioxide and an acidic environment it
allows it to release it where it is most
needed where there's the most carbon
dioxide where respiration is occurring
most rigorously so it's a or vigorously
so it's a fascinating fascinating scheme
and just to get a better understanding
of it right here i have a this little
chart right here that shows the oxygen
uptake by hemoglobin or how saturated
can be and you might see this in in
maybe your biology class it's a good
thing to understand
so right here we have on the on the
x-axis or the horizontal axis we have
the partial pressure of oxygen and if
you watch the chemistry lectures on
partial pressure you know that partial
pressure just means how frequently are
you being bumped into by oxygen pressure
is just is generated by gases or
molecules bumping into you or it doesn't
have to be gas but just molecules
bumping into you and then the partial
pressure of oxygen is the amount of that
that's generated by oxygen molecules
bumping into you so you can imagine as
you go to the right there's just more
and more oxygen around so you're going
to get more and more bumped into by
oxygen so this is just essentially
saying how much oxygen is around as you
go to the right axis and then the
vertical axis tells you how saturated
are your hemoglobin molecules you know
this hundred percent would mean all of
the ahime groups on all of the
hemoglobin
molecules or proteins have bound to
oxygen zero means that none have
so when you have an environment with
very little oxygen and this actually
shows the cooperative binding
so let's say we're we're just dealing
with you know
an environment with very little oxygen
so once a little bit of oxygen binds
then it makes it even more likely that
more and more oxygen will bind as soon
as a little that's why the slope is
increasing i don't want to go into
algebra and calculus here but as you see
we're kind of flattish and then the
slope increases so as we bind to some
oxygen it makes it more likely that
we'll bind to more and at some point it
just you know it's hard for oxygens to
bump just right into the right
hemoglobin molecules but you can see
that it kind of accelerates right around
here now if we have an environment with
a lot an acidic environment that has a
lot of carbon dioxide so that the
hemoglobin is allosterically inhibited
it's not going to be as good at this so
in an acidic environment this curve for
any for any level of oxygen partial
pressure or any amount of oxygen we're
going to have less bound hemoglobin so
let me do that in a different color
so then the the curve would look like
this the saturation i wanted to do
darker
the saturation curve will look like this
so this is an environment
right here
so this is an acidic
environment maybe there's some carbon
dioxide right here so the hemoglobin
the hemoglobin
is being allosterically inhibited
inhibited so it's more likely to dump
the oxygen at this point so i don't know
i don't know how exciting you found that
but i find it brilliant because it
really is the simplest way for these
things to dump their oxygen where needed
no gps needed no no robots needed to say
oh i'm now in the in the quadriceps and
the guy is running let me dump my oxygen
it just does it naturally because it's a
more acidic environment with more carbon
dioxide it gets inhibited and then the
oxygen gets dumped and ready to use for
respiration